PewDiePie: Try not to smile-
~kys~
Who said that?
~Boy, kys~
Who said that?!
Anyway...
Try not to smile...
~I don't belong here!~
Who keeps doing that?
~I belong to someone else~
Try not to smile ch...
~I shouldn't exist.~
OOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!  PB: ~Why do I exist, Why do I exist, Why do I exist...~
~Why do I exist?~
Wow
The play button has a voice...
~Please kill me~ (gladly, hand me the 1000 degree knife, pls.)
It's almost as innovative as this video idea.
(great movie maker intro, pewds.)
UGHH
Well you know what??!
I accept the challenge!
Jesus-
Oh it's heavy
I ACCEPT
*fixes camera*
ugh
f*ck
Kid screams like a girl...
"AHH!"
"AAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!"
Not even a-
c h u c k l e
"AHH!"
"AAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!"
*gr8 music m8* *v epic partay timez*
You know what? Ok well, you know what? This might actually be a girl!
So,
Excuse me "craven_14"
for assuming
A little girl's gender!
Even though I technically just-
Did assu-
Don't assume gender!
Oh God, the title, just the title made me...
Hey! The video hasn't started.
ehHEH
It doesn't count!
That's a stupid fucking title...
Oh, it's Fox News!
I expected, a...
a fox and, uh... yeah.
Well, f**k it. Let's just watch.
"And I'm live here at the San Diego yacht and boat show."
"Good morning everybody. I'm hanging out with my friend, John."
"FOX 5 MORNING NEWS starts."
"Look over there."
"And it starts right now-"
(marvelous fail)
Oh, this is easy.
Feel free to play along, by the way.
"FOX 5 MORNING NEWS starts."
"And it starts right now-"
All he had to do was watch over there. Was that so hard?!
Clearly he doesn't know why he has to- keep eye contact with the camera.
IT STARTS RIGHT NOW!
moVING ON
Oh that's fun- That's funny- I haven't watched the video-
But that's funny.
"Wait a minute."
"This isn't my world."
"disaPPOINTEEED!"
*poods tries to keep from bursting out in laughter, but ultimately fails*
That was good.
*Snickers*
Oh that's funny.
*Chuckles*
"This isn't my world."
I love how he's so into it.
"DISAPPOINTED!"
Like, just knowing the fact that I that I will never be that good of- good of an actor makes me "DISAPPOINTED!"
He doesn't even say it in a disappointing tone, you know what? F**k it, I lost  that one, fine. 2, 1. BRING IT.
"GET THE WHEELS ON THE BUS!!!" *glass breaks* "Way to go, PAUL."
*snickers*
Knew it was coming *sniff* I knew it was happening.
(WEAKLING)
But it still worked.
"GET THE WHEELS ON THE BUS!!!" *glass breaks* Way to go, PAUL.
Typical Paul! Typical Paul behavior! F**kin' Paul bitch.
*chokes wholeheartedly*
Jesus! What the f**k?!
That's danger- you know what, no, it's just hilarious.
"A handbaaaaaaag?"
*snickers*
I'm so f**kin' bad. That was not even that funny. Let's do it a-
"A handbaaaaaaaag?"
*chuckles*
Wut?
"'A handbaaaaaaaag??"
(overlays) A handbaaaaaag?
Alright. Now this- this last video, we saved the best for last!
~Kill yourself.~
You really have a comment about everything don't ya?
Mr S E P T I C E Y E  2!!!
"I don't- I dunno how I'm gonna keep doing the vlogs so-"
"It's just not worth it."
*Sad music plays* "I said it before, but I never wanna force content, y'know?"
"I really have a lot of fun when I'm in my own setup. I need to put myself first."
"This time."
*scoff* This is easy, I'm not gonna smile at this, this is so sad!
Wait a minute!
*pewds looks creepily satisfied* (NEVER AGAIN SHALL WE LIKE)
*snickers*
Got 'em! *chuckles*
*claps* WELL!
That was another try not to, NO THAT WAS THE FIRST "Try Not To Smile" challenge! Oh man!
This is a- this channel just keeps, keep going up!
Thank you for watching! Did you leave a smile? Did you smile? Leave a like!
And uh... ah- that was the deal, as part of the the video.
Come on. Smile a little bit.
You have such a- cute smile, come on, give me it. Give me a little smirk.
Come on.
I know- I know you want to.
I KNOW YOU WANT- come on!
There it is, oh!
Now you gotta leave a like! (greedy poodiepie)
and thank you for watching!
I'll see you bros in the next video! And as ALWAYS...
BROFIST!!!
still here?
lol can you believe how greeeedy pewds is? >:(
most likely...
this IS 2016 gatdam Trump supporter
(lol jk)
lol well i'm karigan @kaiisjoe <3
mad love for Stephano cuz he ain't greeds
can we #StephIsn'tGreedy ?
BRRRRRRRRRRRRRR <3